for a store near you.
.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DRIVEN
MUCH OF THE MAINSTREAM IMMEDIATE
YO BONKERS ONCE AGAIN AND FOX
NEWS IS AMONG ONE OF THE OUTLETS
WITH THE REPORTS AND DURING A
CONFERENCE ON THE IMMIGRATION
TODAY THAT WE WERE JUST TALKING
HERE AND WHY ARE WE HAVING ALL
OF THESE PEOPLE FROM BLANK HOLE
COUNTRIES LIKE HAITI AND EL
SALVADOR, WHERE MS-13 IS FROM
AND CNN TOTALLY FREAKED OUT.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS RACIST
DANCE AROUND THAT ISSUE?
>> JEFFREY TUBIN TALKING ABOUT
DANCING IS NOT SOMETHING THAT I
WANT TO THINK ABOUT.
LET'S WELCOME IN IMMIGRATION
ATTORNEY, MICHAEL WILD IN NEW
YORK AND LET'S GO TO YOU ON THIS
ISSUE ON THE BLANK HOLE
COUNTRIES AND BECAUSE HE SAID
THAT AND TUBIN AND ACOSTA GO TO
THE SAME OLD TUNE AND BECAUSE HE
SAID THAT, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
OBVIOUSLY HARBORING ILL WILL
TOWARDS PEOPLE OF COLOR.
>> AND THIS IS THE BEST NIGHT TO
WATCH CNN.
IT IS FANTASTIC.
I STILL WANT A WALL AND HE'S NOT
GOING TO WIN ME BACK WITH HIS
RHETORIC AGAIN AND IN THE
MEANTIME, IT IS NOT UNTIL WE
ACTUALLY SEE A WALL.
AND THIS IS WHAT ALL OF THE
SPONSORS OF THE 1965 IMMIGRATION
ACT PROMISED US.
KENNEDY AND ALL OF LEGISLATORS
SWORN UP AND DOWN AND SAID THAT
AFRICA OR ANY ONE COUNTRY AND
THEY ARE ACTING EXACTLY OPPOSITE
OF THAT.
BASICALLY, THE WESTERN EUROPEAN
IMMIGRATION WAS SHUT DOWN AND IF
ANYBODY COMPLAINS ABOUT IT, THEY
ARE CALLING YOU A RACIST.
WAS TEDDY KENNEDY A RACIST?
NO, IT IS NOT TRUE.
AND THEY CAN'T SPEAK ENGLISH AND
IF WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
FOR THE WALL AND A LOT OF THESE
COUNTRIES ARE SUCH FANTASTIC
COUNTRIES AND MAYBE WE CAN SHUT
>> AND MICHAEL, I WANT TO GO TO
YOU ON THIS AND YOUR REACTION TO
THE PRESIDENT'S COMMENT?
>> I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU LAURA
FOR HAVING ME AND I HAVE ACTED
ON BEHALF OF THE PRESIDENT AND I
HAVE REPRESENTED MRS. TRUMP AND
I DON'T THINK THIS IS A BIG IF.
THIS IS A CONTENTIOUS ISSUE AND
I THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE ACTING WITH BETTER
CHOICE OF WORDS AND THE DIALOGUE
HAS MIGRATED AND THIS ISSUE IS
FESTERING AND IT IS A HALLMARK
OF THE 1965 ACT AND NOW, GIVEN
THE DEROGATORY TERM OF "CHAIN
MIGRATION".
AND WE HAVE 50,000 LOTTERY VISAS
YES, THERE IS SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE AND YES, I'M
ALL FOR OR ADDING MORE VENDORS,
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT WE WANT
MS-13 HERE.
>> LET ME SHARE SOMETHING WITH
OUR VIEWERS AND I LOG ON TO THE
WEBSITE AND MSN WEBSITE AND COOL
ISSUES THAT I CARE ABOUT AND
HEROIN IS ONE OF THEM AND THERE
IS A MAJOR HEROIN BUST IN
COLORADO THIS WEEK AND COUNTS
AGAINST 61 INDIVIDUALS.
AND THE SUSPECTS, JUAN MEZA AND
AND THE SUSPECTS, JUAN MEZA AN
AND THE SUSPECTS, JUAN MEZ
AND THE SUSPECTS, JUAN MEZ A
AND THE SUSPECTS, JUAN MEZ A&M
AND THE SUSPECTS, JUAN MEZ A&M A
ARE ALL ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND
$264,000 WORTH OF DRUGS,
INCLUDING HEROIN AND WE KNOW
WHAT HEROIN IS DOING TO OUR
YOUTH AND SOCIETY AND IT IS
POISONING THEM.
MANY OF THESE KIDS COULD HAVE
BEEN DACA RECIPIENTS IF THEY HAD
NOT BEEN BUSTED IN A HEROIN
WRING?
THEY COULD HAVE RECEIVED DACA AM
AMNEST
AMNESTY, COULD THEY NOT?
>> GET THEM OUT.
ARE YOU GOING TO INFLATE WITH
THE IMMIGRANTS.
>> AGAIN, MICHAEL, THIS MAY WORK
IN YOUR LAW PRACTICE, BUT NOT
WITH ME.
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
TAXING OUR POLICE, OUR DISTRICT
>> THEY HAVE NOT BEEN CONVICTED
CRIMINALS.
>> OH, THEY ARE VALUE LEK
TORIANS.
WE CAUGHT THEM.
HOW MANY DIDN'T WE CATCH?
>> THERE ARE TWO ISSUES THAT ARE
RELEVANT HERE.
AND THE SUPPORTERS OF DACA AND
IF YOU ADD THEM TOGETHER, THEY
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AND EVEN
THOUGH MOST OF THE PEOPLE ARE
PERFECT
PERFEC
PERFECTLY INNOCENT THEY SERVE AS
A COVER FOR RINGS LIKE THIS.
THESE GUYS ARE NOT OPERATING IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. WHERE WE ARE
BROADCASTING FROM RIGHT NOW.
GO BACK TO VALENTINE'S DAY LAST
YEAR.
A FEMALE MS-13 GANG MEMBER HAD
ANOTHER FEMALE GIRL IN HER GRIP
AND KILLING HER.
SHE STABBED HER MULTIPLE TIMES.
THIS IS FROM FOX FIVE NEWS HERE
IN WASHINGTON.
WATCH.
>> HOW DID YOU KILL HER?
>> WITH A KNIFE.
>> SHE SAID TO HER ALSO, YOU
WILL SEE ME AGAIN IN HELL, DON'T
FORGET MY NAME.
ALL REPORTED AND ALL ADMITTED
BEEN TAKEN AND SHOULD HAVE NEVER
TELLING YOU, ANY DESTRUCTION OF
LIFE, PROPERTY, RAPE, CHILD
ABUSE, DWI, WHY DO THE LIBERALS
HAVE TO TOLERATE THIS, SO THEY
FEEL BETTER ABOUT THEIR CHANCES
IN THE ELECTORAL PROCESS?
>> THAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR?
>> NO, THIS YEAR.
>> SO, THAT'S IN TRUMP'S AMERICA
AND WE HAVE TO FLASH BACK TO
TRUMP PROMISING.
>> SORRY, THE KILLING HAPPENED
ON VALENTINE'S DAY LAST YEAR.
>> AND THE CHILDREN MURDERED BY
ILLEGAL ALIENS AND BROUGHT IT
FRONT AND CENTER STAGE AND TRUMP
SAID I WON'T BETRAY YOU AND IF
TRUMP DOESN'T GO FORWARD IN
BUILDING THE WALL AND IT IS
GOING TO BE ON HIS RECORD AND
THE NEXT PULSE NIGHTCLUB AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE HIS AND HE
BETTER REMEMBER THE PEOPLE WHO
PUT HIM THERE.
>> THE DIALOGUE IS DETERIORATING
SADLY WHERE MOST CRIMINALS ARE
DACA OR ILLEGAL ALIENS.
>> WHAT IF THAT WERE YOUR
DAUGHTER WITH 12 KNIFE WOUNDS IN
HER NECK.
PARTICIPANTS.
>> I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
>> DON'T TELL ME! YOU NEED TO